our large please so teenage
environmentalist Greta thong Berg's
icy stare at Donald Trump has got to be
the image of the week this week in case
you missed it here it is
I mean what a perfect encapsulation of
the entire climate crisis summed up in
this one
spontaneous photograph taken at the UN
climate summit so we've got the US
presidents hot air on the one hand and
the Swedish teenagers frosty glare on
the other harnessing the power of all
that hatred it's enough to refreeze the
ice caps they're a bit like bookends
aren't they Greta and trunk bookends to
the climate change debate and I'm an
environmentalist you lot of people don't
understand that I have done more
environmental impact statements probably
than anybody that's I guess I can say
definitely well despite that convincing
display he doesn't even believe the
evidence whereas Greta she might believe
it a bit too much for her and good
people are suffering people are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is the money
and fairytales of eternal economic
growth does it seem funny to you that a
16 year old teenager has got a better
speechwriter then the 73 year old
president of the United States or that
Trump is the one that responded like a
angry adolescent on Twitter
so Greta hit back with this lovely
little zinger obviously there must have
been a sense of humor hiding in there
somewhere so this is where we have this
Greta thumb bug dilemma in full effect
because she's escalated this tactic of
scaring the hell out of everyone over
climate change but no one likes being
told off by a teenager do they I mean
what are they no but but great they're
haters I mean I just feel like
comfortable that she has got Asperger's
they're even worse I mean she's only a
kid in case you missed it Greta thumb
burg and Donald Trump